- Ourselves of course we are educators,
we are able to inspire our learners.
In my case, if let's say
I want to encourage people
to design buildings better,
it's not just a question of
showing them the principles
but we have to actually
construct a building
and ask them to come
inside it, feel how it is,
then they'll be more interested
and say, "Yes, this works."
And then they can try it on their own.
- We could take it to step
further, really, to say
okay, if we are introducing circularity,
what are the other options?
Because people then they need options.
If I look at the history
of textiles in Africa,
in Zambia, in particular,
we have people that already
are using tree fibres
to make a clothes.
- I think this is one topic
which is common for both of us
I work in the field of
construction industry, of course
but we use natural fibres a lot,
so pineapple fibers,
banana fibres and coconut.
- I think that has potential to dominate
or to be very, very
powerful in the future.
- Actually, I have got high hopes
from the young generation
because I think they are
environmentally aware now.
When we talk of these things to them,
they seem to want to do things,
but it's not always possible
for them to know what to do.